when upgrading node pools in a gke
cluster you probably care about a few
important things do workloads remain as
available as possible during the upgrade
can we mitigate risk with granular
control of upgrades and rollbacks how do
we manage cost speed and the duration of
an upgrade in this episode we're going
to work through how to navigate these
important questions when using the node
pool upgrade strategies built into gke
[Music]
in gke there are two no pool upgrade
strategies gke has surge upgrades in
which nodes in a node pool are upgraded
in a rolling fashion with surge upgrades
you can control how many nodes are
upgraded at once adjusting this to the
disruption that your workloads can
tolerate gke also has blue green
upgrades in which all old or blue nodes
are kept in the node pool during the
upgrade as you validate your workloads
on the new or green nodes let's start by
reviewing the default node pool upgrade
strategy a pre-configured surge upgrade
and we'll use an example node pool that
has three nodes
the default node pool upgrade path will
Begin by creating an additional surge
node in the node pool one with the new
version of the node once that node has
completed creating and is ready we'll
briefly have four nodes in our node pool
then the upgrade will begin the process
of turning down one of the old nodes
this involves draining the old node so
existing pods can terminate coordinating
the nodes so new pods won't be scheduled
there and then deleting the node itself
here we can see the benefit of creating
that new node the extra surge node that
temporarily brought our node count above
the Baseline
its extra resources can now be allocated
to pods that have to reschedule from the
old node
this reduces the time it takes to get
pods restarted and working of course
there are considerations when pods are
moving from node to node
like how can we get pods to shut down
gracefully that is how do we let them
know they need to perform tasks and give
them time to do so like closing
connections or flushing things in memory
to disk in kubernetes you can have
workloads specify values for pre-stop
Hooks and a termination grace period in
the Pod spec
these allow you to Define what tasks
your pod should carry out before they
shut down and give them a defined time
to perform them
because upgrades perform a drain the
containers in your pods receive a Sig
term message which allows for them to
begin carrying out these tasks of course
workload availability is more than just
how a single pod shuts down
is about making sure you have enough
pods running to carry out whatever your
workload does this means working through
details like making sure you have enough
pod replicas and that number of replicas
can scale up and down
making sure replicas don't Bunch up on a
couple of nodes using things like node
anti-affinity
and defining rules around keeping a
minimum number of replicas around at any
given time using pod disruption budgets
gke does interact with pod disruption
budgets specifically allowing to block
an upgrade for 60 minutes should one be
violated
but overall these recommendations are
not specific to gke in fact you should
consider these for disruption sensitive
workloads in any kubernetes environment
with that said once the pods have been
drained from the old node that node is
deleted and we repeat the cycle until
the whole node pool is complete the
default upgrade strategy shows us how
surge upgrades work in gke
and while we just went through the
default configuration you can actually
tune a couple of settings to best suit
your needs
the first is called Max surge upgrade
by default this parameter is set to one
we saw this earlier in the default
upgrade strategy when the upgrade
started by adding one surge node above
the Baseline node count
if we were to set this value ourselves
for example 2 2
. during the upgrade the node pool could
surge above the Baseline node count by
two additional nodes
there are a couple of reasons we want to
tune this we may have larger node pools
that we want to finish upgrading faster
so we want to increase the speed of new
nodes being added to the node pool
or we may want to ensure that it's worth
the slightly extra cost to have spare
resources to allocate to PODS moving
around during the upgrade
now on the other side of the coin we
have Max unavailable upgrade as a
tunable field
this is the number of nodes below the
Baseline node count that can be
unavailable at any given time
in the default upgrade strategy this
value is set to zero meaning that the
node pool never drops below ready and
available Baseline node count
if we set this to 1 the upgrade can turn
down nodes at a rate that allows the
upgrade to fall one node below the
Baseline count
by doing so it helps us speed up
upgrades by coordinating and draining
nodes faster
so in this example we left off with five
nodes two that surged above the Baseline
count
this means that our upgrade can now
coordinate and drain up to three nodes
at the same time the faster nodes are
cordoned and drained the more pods are
moving around and being rescheduled at
any given time so again this can be
slightly disruptive for pods but it does
speed up the upgrade process there's a
lot of power in between these two
settings with a lot of configurable
outcomes depending on what's important
to you
could take a slower balanced approach
similar to the default configuration
you could turn down nodes faster than
you create new ones which optimizes for
Speed and lowering the cost of an
upgrade but this can be disruptive if
workloads don't have available resources
to reschedule to
finally you could create nodes faster
than you turn down old ones this
optimizes for Speed and spare capacity
as pods move around
there are also some protections built
into these strategies for example when
you set max surge upgrade to zero you're
protected against any temporary stock
outs should the upgrade not be able to
secure capacity as it adds nodes
there are a lot of different ways you
can use these two settings
surge upgrades give you a lot of control
over the speed of an upgrade and this is
helpful especially in scenarios in which
you have large node pools that need to
go through an upgrade
however no matter what surge upgrades
are performed in a rolling fashion
a trade-off for controlling the speed of
an upgrade is less granular control over
workload disruption and slower rollbacks
should you ever need to so if your
workloads are disruption sensitive and
your priority is to have more control to
mitigate risks during an upgrade you
might consider the other strategy built
into gke blue-green upgrades
this upgrade strategy provides more
control around promotion of new node
versions and safer rollbacks
we can step through an example blue
green upgrade via its phases
we start in the first phase by creating
an entirely new green set of nodes with
the new versions of the nodes we want
more importantly this set of nodes will
be equal to the old blue node count
right at phase one in this example we
add three new green nodes to the node
pool
once those are ready and available we
step into phase two coordinating Old
Blue Notes
after all we don't want newly created
pods to be scheduled to Old nodes only
to be moved again especially since we
can utilize the free and allocatable
capacity of the new nodes
once we've hoarded off the old blue
nodes we can begin the process of
draining them
this will flush any existing pods on
those nodes allowing them to reschedule
to the new green nodes
and this is where we begin to get more
granular control we can Define either an
explicit number of Old Blue nodes to
drain at a time or an explicit
percentage of Old Blue nodes to be
drained at a specific time
this example shows what would happen if
we drain nodes in batches of two until
all of the old blue nodes are drained
we can also Define a window of time to
sit and wait before draining the next
batch of nodes
this helps us move workloads to the new
green nodes as slow as we want all
without having to worry about whether or
not the capacity is available
it's also important to call out that we
are not releasing the old blue nodes
during this time
workloads such as stateful workloads
that need more time to shut down to do
things like flushing memory to disk can
now take that time on the old Blue Note
and if we wanted to roll back for any
given reason the old nodes will be
uncorded and quickly made available for
workloads to schedule back to
once that's done we step into phase four
in which we can define a soak time
duration
this lets us observe how all the
workloads are behaving on the new nodes
and if we need to we can quickly roll
back workloads to the old blue nodes
during this time and we can even
automate this process based on slos that
we set in Cloud monitoring
Now the default soak time is one hour
but we can bump this all the way up to
seven days giving us control to observe
our workloads especially ones with
diurnal or spiky usage patterns
once we've validated our workloads we
can promote the upgrade and release the
old blue nodes that we no longer need
that is if there is still soak time left
the upgrade will also continue if the
soak time expires
it is then that we finally release the
old blue nodes by deleting them
with the upgrade complete we are finally
back at our stable Baseline node count
of three
as you can see blue green upgrades
optimize for stability availability and
risk mitigation
resources are still there to roll back
to as you validate your workloads on the
new set of nodes
the trade-off in this case is the
additional cost of doubling your node
pool resources during the upgrade time
with that said many will evaluate the
cost of a slower rollback process for
critical workloads and take that into
consideration as well
surge upgrades and blue green upgrades
optimize for different things
surge upgrades are better for workloads
where speed is more important to you at
the cost of a little bit of disruption
blue green upgrades are better for
workloads focused on stability
availability and risk mitigation at the
cost of running more nodes for the
duration of the upgrade
the best part is these are on a per node
pool basis in gke we understand that
your cluster may have multiple profiles
of workloads across multiple different
node pools so you can choose your
upgrade strategies accordingly per node
pool of course there's more to follow up
on to fully shape your upgrade strategy
in gke like release channels testing new
versions of gke and pre-prod clusters
and maintenance windows and exclusions
to learn more stay tuned and check out
the links in the description below
thanks for spending this time with me
and we'll see you next time on GK
Essentials
[Music]
foreign